Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hi, everybody.
We're here at Devoxx 2014.
And I'm here with Martin.
MARTIN GORNER: Hello.
INTERVIEWER: Hello, Martin.
And Martin has an
interesting session
here at the conference,
which is called something
like "Nobody Does MapReduce
Anymore at Google."
So Google kind of
invented MapReduce,
and now you tell us,
just a few years later,
when everybody is using it
in various implementations
that this was a bad
idea, in fact, right?
MARTIN GORNER: Well,
the MapReduce paper
was published in 2004.
That's 10 years ago.
You can imagine that the train
has been moving since then.
But actually, yes,
the title of the talk
is a little bit provocative.
There is still a lot
of MapReduce going on.
The reality is that
it would be, I think,
a bad idea to launch
MapReduce as a service
today because what
we are using in-house
is much more powerful than that.
And that's actually what we
will be releasing shortly.
It's called Google
Cloud Dataflow.
INTERVIEWER: So Dataflow.
So this is based on another
paper, which, I believe,
is called FlumeJava.
MARTIN GORNER: Yes, exactly.
INTERVIEWER: And it's a
higher level of abstraction.
So maybe MapReduce
is just one way
to implement whatever
you express in Dataflow.
So walk us through
what Dataflow is.
Maybe for the developer, it's
about dealing with data, right?
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly.
What you want to do is
crunch huge amounts of data.
And when you do
this for a living,
you realize that even
for small problems,
one MapReduce stage
is usually not enough.
You want to have at least two of
them or maybe five of them in--
INTERVIEWER: The
pipeline of MapReduces.
MARTIN GORNER: In
a different graph.
Not just a pipeline.
It could be a graph.
INTERVIEWER: A graph, yes.
MARTIN GORNER: But
two MapReduces,
merging the results,
going into a third one,
and then doing something
else with the data again.
And this, if you try to
implement it using MapReduce,
you end up with
a lot of plumbing
because you need to handle all
those intermediate results.
You need to actually deploy
your MapReduce clusters,
and all that.
So there is a better way.
And the way we are suggesting
to developers to do it
today is to use a
very small number
of high-level primitives--
in Java, for example--
and define the computation
using those primitives.
Those primitives work
on parallel collections
and are executed lazily, which
means that the code you write
is simply used by the
system to infer an execution
graph in memory.
Once we have that graph,
we can optimize it,
and we can deploy the
optimal cluster topology
for actually running
your computation.
Deploy it, run it, tear it down.
Of course, you still
get all the benefits
of MapReduce, which means it's
a parallel execution framework.
The life cycle of the
nodes is handled for you.
Catastrophic events, like a
node dying unexpectedly or not
responding.
That's handled for you.
You really only focus on
the math, the computation
you want to do on your data.
INTERVIEWER: So walk
us through, briefly,
what the API looks
like as a developer.
How do I develop and use this?
What is my input,
output, operations?
What does the API look like?
MARTIN GORNER: So the basic
piece of data you act on
is a P-collection.
That's a parallel collection.
It's an immutable
collection of data.
And then you use
primitives to work on it.
The most basic
primitive is parallelDO,
a parallel operation,
a function you provide.
That's the equivalent
of Map or Reduce
in the MapReduce paradigm.
And then the second important
primitive is a group by key.
So normally, when
you do a parallelDO,
you do computations
on your data,
and you also assign
keys to your data.
So the output is
key value pairs.
And then, again in the
MapReduce paradigm,
you have a group by key,
which is called a shuffle
stage, which will put all
the data with the same key
together and apply another,
usually an aggregation
on those data.
So parallel collections,
parallelDO group by key.
And then a third
primitive, which
is an associative parallelDO
that has a lot of good stuff
that can happen when your
parallelDO is associated.
So with those three
primitives, it's
enough to describe most of the
computations you want to do.
And then FlumeJava also
adds primitives-- well,
not primitives, but
functions, helper functions,
which are already
implemented on top of those,
like counting or adjoin,
or a top operation.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
So you mentioned FlumeJava.
That's the paper that was
published around 2010, I think.
MARTIN GORNER: Yes.
INTERVIEWER: It's
based on experience
Google has running this type
of technology in production.
But what we're offering here
is a product called Dataflow.
And that's a service
we're offering
because you want to focus, as a
developer, on that level of API
you just described and leave to
Google everything else, which
is setting up the environment,
the network, the nodes,
and spinning out the
resources in the most
efficient and fastest way
to provide a result back.
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly.
And the beauty of it is that if
you have a complex computation,
which actually results in
a fairly complex network
topology for your
processing cluster,
if there is something
you need to change,
it's a couple of
lines in your code.
And you hit Enter,
and that cluster
gets redeployed with
a different topology.
That's really how we want
to manage a compute cluster.
You don't want to be
there changing the nodes
and rewiring them because
you need to compute something
slightly differently.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
So the other thing is
the data you work on,
is this like read-only data?
You have a batch of data?
Or can you have some
sort of streaming?
Or is there anything--
MARTIN GORNER: Well, that's
the second, I would say,
magic strong point of
Dataflow is that once
you have your
computation described
in using the
high-level primitives,
to turn this into a
streaming computation,
what you do is that you change
your inputs and outputs.
Instead of reading from a
file, you read from a stream.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
MARTIN GORNER: You
add one line of code,
which is please now work
with this time window.
And that's it.
This cluster becomes a real-time
data processing cluster
that does everything the batch
processing cluster was doing.
There's still node life cycle,
nodes dying, and all that.
All this is handled for you.
But now it can
also automatically
scale with the volume of data.
And if you think
about it inside,
it uses parallel sets of nodes
for executing your parallelDOs.
It can figure out how many
nodes to put in parallel
to actually sustain the flow.
And those parallel
processing groups of nodes,
they're all actually
put together
in a complex execution graph.
But you don't have
to worry about that.
There's an optimizer
that worries about that.
And there is an
executor that worries
about putting the whole
thing on autopilot.
INTERVIEWER: I like
all those things
I don't have to worry about.
So when can I, when can
folks start using this?
This is Dataflow, that's
a service, a product,
Google Cloud is offering soon?
MARTIN GORNER: So
we've been using it
for many years at Google,
which means that it's not
a completely
non-baked technology.
And in the session today,
you will see a live demo.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
MARTIN GORNER: So
that's the status.
INTERVIEWER: So, yeah.
That's a good plug
for your session,
for people to watch
this on [INAUDIBLE]
as soon as it's published.
MARTIN GORNER: Indeed.
INTERVIEWER: So, Martin.
I think that's all the
time we have for it.
So thanks for doing this, and
good luck with the session.
And folks, keep an
eye on Cloud Dataflow.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: Thanks, everyone.